let's say you guys break up as as
couples will do
yeah um you get all your money back or
he takes them no
no i mean i'm the [ __ ]
so therefore everything still go to him
probably even when i'm not his [ __ ] i'm
still his [ __ ]
so
all right mariah where are you from
where'd you grow up originally
um i grew up in chicago illinois
and uh tell me about your family you had
both your parents when you were growing
up
yeah i grew up with um with my parents
um they were separated but um
i still have both of them in my life how
was how was your childhood
actually i grew up i had a good spoiled
childhood
um an interesting childhood
but um in what ways
um i mean i lived the the
the normal childhood life
getting everything i wanted spoiled i
guess that's why i'm a brat now
but like any traumatic events in your
childhood any abuse anything like that
um well when i was younger
i um
i was kind of like molested when i was
younger growing up
um i was around 12.
who did this um it was actually with
one of my mom's boyfriend
so did you say anything at the time
no i didn't but over the years as it
went by
and that's when i um actually start
seeing things about it so continued
for a longer period of time yes
do you ever catch the guy um
over the years you know i still see him
around
every now and then i still see him
around but um
i really don't say much to him but i
have confronted him about it
and you uh what kind of kid were you in
high school say what what kind of kid
were you in high school
oh my gosh i was um
a outgoing kid i um
did a lot of sports
volleyball basketball
um you're popular you had friends
no i was not the popular type in school
i was more of the loner the loner didn't
get along well with others
stayed in my own lane quiet i was quiet
didn't hang around a big crowd
[Music]
and then you you left home at what age i
left home i moved home when i was 16.
where'd you go i moved to atlanta
i had ran away moved to atlanta i stayed
in atlanta from
about six years six seven years and then
from atlanta i came here
did you finish high school no you didn't
no and what were you doing i dropped out
like in the 11th grade
okay yeah and how are you supporting
yourself then
um at that time yeah um i start
prostituting
um getting into the big that type of
life
and everything like that and um
had a pimp and that's that's how
i survived yeah and today you're working
with the pimp are you on your own
no um always worked with a pimp
always like had someone with me out
there
including today yes always what's what's
the advantage of working with a pimp
for you um
because i hear many of the girls say
hell no i would never do that
why give him i mean
it's for each is on you know um
[Music]
protection keep you stabilized
everything like that
and your relationship with with your
pimp is is good you like it's open
yes it's it's different for each his own
you know it's open
you know i'm an open open book myself so
it's
open but he treats you well
um every relationship has
problems the fights the black eyes you
know you don't make the money
you know it's consequence yeah
so you do you have children no no no
never married no you're young how old
are
you
i'm 28. you're 28. yeah
so when you decided to move from atlanta
to la you you went with your pimp or you
went on your own and
relocated um no when i first went to
atlanta i went by myself
and then when you came from atlanta to
l.a then when i came from l.a
i mean to atlanta to here i already had
my pimp by then i met him out there
and he came with you out here i see
you ever you ever been arrested no
never no
you've had you've had rough experiences
doing this um
i've been robbed um
been jumped on a few times
um and that's when he's not around
um from people with different other
girls set you up
you know so yes it's a rough life it's
definitely a rough life and i don't
encourage nobody to get into it because
it's it's it's
it's a choice but it's also life you
know
sometimes it's that's the experience we
have to go through at times
do you think there's anything in your
childhood that kind of paved the way for
this
this to happen for you
the child abuse or the way no to be
honest i never expected this
i never expected to
be prostituting or none of the things
that i was doing i never
expected it you know i never expected
that at all
did you have did you have dreams of
doing anything else as a kid
um no
actually my dream as a kid i want to be
a street walker
so that you made your dreams come true
kind of huh
so why would a young girl dream about
something like that what is it about
your
i mean when you grow up that made you
think that that was something that you
wanted because you know i always wanted
to do porn
then you know growing up young i used to
want to do porn
did you have these thoughts um i was
like 14
15. really yeah
that's interesting that at such a young
age you you aspired to doing
sex work yes
i i really that's i want to go into that
to that field but i guess
me being so nervous about being on
camera i don't think i would have did it
so
so you never did that no and i probably
still wouldn't
so do you make good money working the
street oh yeah
good money um i can come in i don't want
to say how much i actually come in with
you know
because it's just for safety reasons
yeah but you make good money
oh yes definitely good money and are
drugs are part of the picture for you
no no drugs no drugs um
just never got into the drug thing you
know
that's right um yeah it's very rare um
like i said my man keep me kind of off
with a lot of
things that's great
you recall your first time the first
trick you picked up oh yes
yes yes yes you want to hear about it i
do
um actually my first one
his name was rob actually this is
atlanta um
this is atlanta this was in chicago
you know i started in chicago and worked
my way to atlanta
but the my very first time
i was around 16
16 at that time and it had to been
around like
april and i was walking home from school
and um the car pulled up on me
and everything like that actually i was
ditching
and um i was supposed to been at school
taking my lunch break but ditching and
didn't never go back cause i went with
him
so he wound up approaching me asking me
um
what was my name and then asked me was i
hungry
um how old was i showing me his
um penis it was kind of a turn on
at the time he did that to prove that
he's not a cop
or yeah he kind of did that to prove he
wasn't the cop that's where the guys
that's how the guys prove it
yeah and then he asked me to show a
teddy because he wanted to make sure
that i didn't get him in trouble
and everything like that so i did that
then
we discussed the price i wouldn't jumped
in the car with him
we left and i actually stayed going with
him for like three days
for like three days and typically you'll
do business in a
hotel motel or a car or a hotel motel
car
alley the streets wherever wherever
and you practice safe sex i assume
always
yeah and the guys will want
what kind of sexual interaction
all kinds all kinds
it's really no limits of no limits
what's the craziest request you've had
i've heard so many girls talking crazy
stuff yes like
i have men's that wants
you to like urinate on them
um urinating their your their mouth
um they have
anal fetishes feet fetishes
where they pay like extreme amount you
know
so
but i think the most one that got me is
when the man asked me to like
poop in his mouth that was like you know
that one right there was just like a lot
for me
yeah so you've been around you've heard
you've heard you've heard all the crazy
requests oh yes yes so
your pimp keeps all your money yes
but the the the reason you're okay with
that is he's
gonna manage that money and and help you
do what um to a certain extent
it helps me out you know it helps us out
but um we're still in a relationship too
so
let's say you guys break up as as
couples will do yeah
and you get all your money back or he
takes the money no
no i mean i'm the [ __ ]
so therefore everything's still go to
him
probably even when i'm not his [ __ ] i'm
still his [ __ ]
so it's consequences and that that
thinking i'm sure will become
like a source of a lot of comments on
this video
what is it about your childhood
made you believe that that's an okay way
to interact with a with a male
that giving him all your you you're
working you're you're risking your life
and
and your health and all kinds of
self-esteem issues you're giving
the pimp all your money and if anything
goes sour
he he runs off with the money and you're
left with what nothing
nothing and you're okay with all that
you have no choice
you either gonna deal with it or you're
not
you know um
or when he see you out there they beat
you and take it from you
so you either ask if you do you ask if
you don't
so and if you were to go out on your own
or if you you told him you're gonna
go renegade at one point how would that
um most of the time he's around
but they still go off and do their own
thing but they still be around
you know they they make their rounds
so if if you if you were on your own
a renegade as they call it you'd still
have to give away your money you think
um good question
good question well i don't know because
i still know other girls that
don't have pimps or nothing like that
and they still giving out their money
and still getting beat up by people yeah
yes it's it's a tough one so it's it's
i guess um
it's about the strong ones only the
strong will survive
yeah what personality trait do you do
you have that helps you
helps you do this helps you survive
prayer
that's about it prayer help me survive
everything
even though i do what i do it still
helps me survive
and getting out there doing what i need
to do
does he get you down sometimes of course
you're depressed
i mean everybody does mm-hmm everybody
have the press they don't in starbucks
you get depressed
but there's certain things about this
line of work that
can make you feel like you are yeah but
see you guys
know how to cut the
depression off you gotta know how to cut
all that off
and live you know
we go through a lot from being raped out
here
to to being abused
even at home or anywhere else so
you got to really have some tough skin
out here
you got to really have some tough skin
does your family know you're doing this
um no
no my family don't know what i do
they um actually i ran away and left my
family years ago
kind of you still have contact with them
in every blue moon i contact them like
i haven't really talked to them in like
three four years
like kind of went m.i.a
were the things going on at home that
made you run away at 16 and
now not have contact with your family
yes
a lot of problems lots of problems at
home
so i just went on and left home and i
left like i said i left at 16
and uh moved to land and i never i never
went back
never went back
what do you think the most misunderstood
thing about this lifestyle like
for people that don't do it don't
understand it they'll
they'll hear your story and go that's
crazy why would why would a girl ever do
that
sometimes you put in a predicament
we all have choices but sometimes
you have to take another path to
get what you need at times you know
um
and how else can i explain that like
well the options that you had at 16.
it's not
really too many options when you're
young
you have so many you have options
but not many you know so when you get
hungry
you don't have a shelter over your head
you don't have nobody but yourself and
then yeah a lot of people look and be
like
why still turning that you wouldn't know
you when you have absolutely
nothing nothing
and you did pray and you have
tried to come up with different
solutions
and you came up with that solution
and it worked you stick with what was
working for you at that time you ever
find yourself doing things other than
trading sex for money are you sometimes
maybe
getting the guys watch or is
um no i'm honest with them you know i
don't
rob my dolls or anything like that i'd
like to keep it straight
100 with them because
i don't want to get them hurt and then i
wouldn't want to put myself in that
predicament
because every car i jump in is
definitely a
95 chance that i've never probably can
come back again
yeah what was the best time of your life
when were your happiest
when i was a kid
young girl um
yeah 16 on down
and it was like the best times of my
life
what was the worst
this right now um corona
it's hard to make money for a girl right
no
the pandemic is easy
this is this is easy money out here with
the pandemic
um it's just um
the deaths
that's how can i say it all the deaths
[Applause]
bad news you know people have died um
no i just the hearing about it
and things like that the the stories
is very stressful so
do you think you're addicted to this
lifestyle do you think getting out would
be difficult good question
just just telling your pimp you're going
to quit next week and you're going to
get a job at nordstrom's and
no that's not going to happen i'm in it
to win it
you ever stand back and just look at
your life and go man this is this is
just nuts that i'm doing this it's crazy
because it is a crazy lifestyle no not
yet no
maybe because i'm enjoying it so much
right now
you're still enjoying it still enjoying
it i'm young
why not it's exciting oh it's different
it's different very different
hell is sex every day today millenniums
love sex
i get best of both worlds money is sex
you've been in love before no i'm not in
love
i say [ __ ] love
you're making money make money
thank you so much for sharing your story
you're welcome so glad we met
glad to meet you too good luck out there
thank you
all right mariah thank you very much
you're welcome thanks
you know
you